hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
pe.l2-3.10.5 control and manage physical
access devices
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone and sad
trying to understand all the cmmc dfars
and nist SP 800 171 compliance stuff on
top of an already colossal workload I've
got great news for you you are not alone
and it's gonna be okay because you found
us and with us we're going to make you
into the next on-call compliance hero so
you can help transform your organization
into a more secure more compliant better
place to be let's get into it alright so
uh here we have a requirement to make
sure that all physical access devices
that is key fobs keys and any other
devices or even biometric data used to
log in or access a part of the facility
is controlled okay you gotta have
control over that stuff right if you got
15 people walking around with the door
to your house
it's not really a very secure house is
it we don't want that we want to know
where these keys are we want to make
sure we have them you know that we're
accountable for them
Etc so on this you'll want to be
prepared with both evidence of the
systems you use to monitor these items
uh like you know a log and also you'll
want to be prepared to give a
demonstration of how it all works your
systems or standard operating procedures
let's see what the assessors are looking
for on this one
okay three assessment points one
determine if physical access devices are
identified uh again if we were to answer
this we'd say hey it's implemented all
physical access devices are inventoried
and logged by the CIO or the chief
operations officer or the door guy or
the facilities security officer fso
whatever the relevant person is in your
organization somebody uh has to have
this down now second assessment Point
determine if physical access devices are
controlled implemented physical access
devices are controlled by in this case
the CIO right because well let's just be
honest if you're an I.T guy they just
kind of like lay everything on you and
that's just how it goes because it
connects to the network but ultimately
in all seriousness again somebody's got
to have physical access devices that are
controlled which means that you can you
know again go find them if you need to
and they're used within their specified
purposes determine if physical access
devices are managed implemented physical
access devices are managed by the CIO
base based on the physical access device
policy so again here's a big hint you're
probably going to have to have some
policy somewhere that relates to how
physical access devices are allocated
given out returned Etc so all those
things yep they require another policy
and if you're struggling on the policy
writings I know this is a really hard
one the good news is uh if you're if you
need help with this stuff give us a
shout I'll give you some information in
a second we handle all of the policies
for you right so we take care of all the
policies we take care of all of the
compliance the plans everything and
again if you're on The Struggle Bus
trying to figure this out or you're
banging your head against your monitor
trying to figure out what to do now the
good news is at on-call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seal on a sunny day when we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc compliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now
and if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance learns
roll it out until the next Appliance tip
my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
[Music]